how to farm millions of pounds of
blackberries cultivation and harvesting
techniques in 2024 blackberries are a
highly popular fruit due to their rich
flavor High nutritional value and
versatility in culinary applications
farming millions of pounds of
blackberries requires strategic planning
meticulous cultivation and efficient
harvesting techniques this guide
outlines the essential steps for
successful Blackberry farming in 2024
covering site selection soil preparation
planting maintenance pest control and
harvesting site selection choosing the
right location is crucial for Blackberry
farming the ideal site should have well-
draining soil access to full sunlight
and protection from strong winds
blackberries thrive in slightly acidic
to neutral soil
elevation and slope can also affect
drainage and sun exposure so gentle
slopes are preferable soil preparation
before planting the soil must be
prepared to provide optimal growing
conditions for blackberries conduct a
soil test to determine pH and nutrient
levels based B on test results amend the
soil by adding lime to raise pH or
sulfur to lower it incorporate organic
matter such as compost or aged manure to
improve soil structure and fertility
from now on let's explore the entire
process of growing harvesting packing
blackberries including Factory processes
and storage all while enjoying some
great music
[Music]